and the Civil Service have had the
lowest pay award anywhere in the economy
two percent even though inflation is at
10 and food inflation is at 16. we've
tried for months to get the government
to engage in discussions and they're not
even prepared to put money on the table
at the moment even though it's now been
revealed that in two government
departments alone DWP and the tax
offices 47
000 people will get a pay raise on the
first of April because they're now on
the national minimum wage so people who
are delivering key decisions across a
range of Public Services have had their
pay cut for 10 consecutive years now
qualify for the national minimum wage so
there's a crisis of inward poverty forty
thousand civil servants using food banks
forty five thousand civil servants are
claiming in-work benefits the very
definition of the inwork poor but the
government seems happy to give its own
Workforce
far less even than everyone else has
been offered and has rejected into going
on strike over so this is necessary I'm
afraid where's the money going to come
from to give you
well we clearly think there's lots of
money available to be frank um it's a
matter of political priority the
government claim it would cost I think
29 billion to give every public sector
worker what they've asked for our
calculations is actually would cost near
a 10 billion if you take into account
the tax and insurance that is paid and
10 billion pounds in an economy like
ours can easily be found and we know
that this government in the form of Liz
trust a conservative government was
prepared to borrow 200 billion pounds
for tax cuts so it's a matter of if they
prioritize paramedics job center workers
and Border force staff or they're happy
to see those people claim benefits and
use food banks this is a list of what
you're looking for from the government
the
I suppose a Chancellor and thus the
Prime Minister would say to you in
response we cannot do this because it
will fuel inflation
well I don't think any serious Economist
believes that the current inflation is
anything to do with pay
and our view is the Bank of England is
trying to cut the inflation Target but
the bank of England is also worried
about a recession we narrowly missed a
recession last time
most people accept that if you're going
into a recession the last thing you want
is for people to be impoverished and
have no money to spend we need people to
be able to support the hospitality
sector the manufacturing sector and if
PCS members were to get a pay raise I
can say to UK they would not be putting
it in the Cayman Islands or tax-free
Investments they would spend it because
people are desperate and in our view
that has a boosting effect on the
economy and it is something that could
easily be afforded and economically
would be a wise thing to do
which departments how will my viewers at
home this morning be affected will there
be a lot of effects today it's a one day
strike so job centers will be closed
today there's already picket lines at
our airports and our ports museums and
galleries will be closed passport
offices will be closed the driving and
vehicle license agency will be closed
the Welsh Parliament for example can't
sit today the Scottish Parliament will
be seriously disrupted so across all
parts of government life there will be
picket lines today and there will be no
public service and that's for one day
but we've also announced that because
this can't just be about a protest
there's going to be a week of strike
action at the British museum there's
going to be four days of strikes at the
borders including Dover and Calais and
Dunkirk and that's going to involve
significant disruption so our message to
the government
is rather than just duck this rather
than accept all this disruption you must
accept there is an economic and moral
case to say we cannot have civil
servants claiming the benefits they
administer visiting food banks and
Beyond the national minimum wage
looks as though I mean certainly from
what we heard from the education sector
this morning they're not going to budge
they're not going to budge do you
anticipate another day of action when
half a million workers will be on strike
I anticipate there'll be more than that
the next time I think there's a day of
action because the government's position
is unsustainable now let's be clear they
do u-turns at a pretty rapid rate we've
seen Richie soon out do a number of
u-turns it's not feasible that they can
sit back with this unprecedented amount
of industrial action growing because
it's half a million today next week we
have paramedics and we have nurses there
will then be the firefighters we know
have now voted for strike action so the
amount of people taking or voting for
Action is going to grow and I don't
believe the government will find it can
get away with putting its head down
while all this disruption takes place
and I think they'll be forced to take a
much more realistic attitude but if they
refuse
we are planning for our campaign to
continue right through the summer with
both long-term sustained targeted
strikes but also Mass actions like today
and I think we will see if there is
another one it will be even bigger than
the one today and when do you think
anticipate that might happen
well this strikes next week as we know
um we know that the teachers unions for
example have announced two days of
strike action in March one of those days
is uh on budget day and I think it would
be a fair guess to say that lots of
unions will be looking to see whether
that is a really good time for us to
come back together
but that's a long time away okay and if
Richie sunac is watching your program or
Jeremy Hunt well they both do good
morning I I think they need to realize
that they can't get away with this they
cannot have this inward poverty in this
country at this level and they kind of
have the disruption that we're seeing
and they're going to have to do
something about it and the sooner they
get on and do that the better so just to
clarify you're saying that if the Union
the government doesn't come back with
more money an offer of a decent amount
of money in your opinion than in six
weeks time we will see more than 500 000
workers on strike all on the same day
I'm saying that if the government
refused to improve any offers and
doesn't put money on the table there
will be more and more strikes and given
we already know that the teachers have
already announced a two-day strike in
the 15th and 16th of March I think it's
very likely that other unions May well
take the same decision our Union's
national executive committee will meet
next week and we will take a decision on
future action and that'll be one of the
things that we'll be discussing what do
you need what what can the government do
in order to stop that
money now we cannot have a situation
where they tell us you just have to wait
I mean our 2023 pay which they tell us
to wait for in some cases isn't due till
August I mean to be honest the energy
bills are going up in April the crisis
is now and we need money now and we've
made that absolutely clear but we also
need in the Civil Service an agreement
they're not going to cut the tens of
thousands of jobs they're threatening to
cut they're not going to cut our members
redundancy terms okay by a staggering 33
is the cuts they want to make they want
to make tens of thousands redundant and
cut their contractual redundancy by a
third and also yesterday we're in the
high court because they know that our
pensions are currently unfair and we're
paying too much for our pensions despite
an independent public sector valuation
so in short treat us with the dignity
and respect we deserve we were clapped
in the pandemic now give us money to
advertise crisis 30 seconds to Affair
one final word for uh Jacob Reese mug
who said we don't need this many civil
servants
what we don't need is Jacob we smoke